the number of newly reported covid19
cases
in the u.s topping 200 000 for the first
time
in a single day happening on friday the
nation
also logging more than 1400 deaths
the total number of infections in the
u.s surpassing
13 million and while a vaccine has yet
to be approved by the fda
united airlines is already laying the
groundwork for quick
distribution the airline began operating
charter flights friday to get
doses of pfizer's covet 19 vaccine
in position let's go to christina
coleman she's live in los angeles with
more christina
hi arthel well the faa is working with
united airlines to prepare for the first
mass shipment of a covid vaccine and
keep in mind this is going to be a
massive logistical effort to distribute
a vaccine
like this worldwide now the faa is going
to allow united to carry 15
000 pounds of dry ice per flight to
maintain the cold temperatures needed to
keep pfizer's vaccine
from spoiling that's apparently five
times what's normally allowed on planes
united plans to fly chartered flights
between brussels and chicago
to support vaccine distribution
according to a letter from the faa
viewed by the wall street journal
if the fda if the fda approves pfizer's
vaccine
after the agency's december 10 hearing
on the matter
distribution could start within 24 hours
the world health organization
says the vaccine's distribution strategy
is key
it may be that it will take some very
clever vaccination strategies to highly
target
people in our society who are more
likely to carry transmit
and super spread with this virus
there's new stricter covet guidelines in
california like many other places in the
country right now
a new three-week stay-at-home order goes
into effect
in the state's most populous county on
monday l.a county is banning public and
private gatherings with mixed households
and residents here are also advised to
stay home as much as they can
and to always wear a face covering over
their nose and mouth when they're
outside
the ban on gatherings does not include
faith-based services or protests
since they are constitutionally
protected rights but the order does put
new occupancy limits on essential and
non-essential retail
personal care services like salons and
also libraries
businesses operating outdoors like
fitness centers museums and zoos and
mini golf and go-kart racing are kept
at 50 percent occupancy and restaurants
have also been ordered to close outdoor
dining
meantime covid cases and
hospitalizations here in california
continue to soar like they are in many
other places
across this country arthel yeah and you
have to wear
the mask over your nose as well as your
mouth and
if pfizer can get those vaccines out if
approved man that'll be great news and
that'll go along with what president
trump predicted
saying that those vaccines may be
available next week or the next
after that all right christina coleman
thank you very much for that update